so the first strategy of mine patterns
is really about how we each uniquely
communicate understand and learn
this is like the hardwiring of your
brain it has nothing to do with
personality it's really the operating
system of your mind and it starts with
attention attention is how we attend to
things in the world and what most people
don't realize is that there's more than
one way of paying attention we consider
attention in one form paying attention
if you imagine my hands as your mind
this is focused attention this is where
details are apparent this is where you
have a lot of concentration the mind
also moves into a second state of
attention this is sorting attention this
is where confusion happens this is where
you're listening or experiencing
something and you're attaching it to
your own stories your own history this
is where the brain is deciding am I
going to keep this piece of information
or am I going to discard it the third
state of attention is open wide wonder
this is where insight happens this is
where you have aha moments in this
culture we tend to only value this state
of attention we will caffeinate
ourselves we will do anything to keep in
this state of attention however in order
to have the type of breakthroughs that
we so desperately need we have to give
ourselves space and time to go into
these wider states of attention the
interesting thing is we each do that in
a different way and so for some visual
information is very important it helps
them focus for others kinesthetic
information or hands-on experiences will
help them remain focus this is the
person you may see fidgeting around a
lot or moving a lot what their mind is
actually doing is trying to pay
attention and still for others auditory
information helps them keep focus
they're very quick with their words the
language they use is very ornate
similarly to get into an open state of
attention for some to get up in the back
of a meeting room and pace around helps
them have that insight they that aha
that breakthrough but if we're in that
meeting room I may look at that person
and go oh my gosh why are they standing
up and walking around I may feel
disrespected when in fact we understand
these types of diversities through the
lens of mind pattern with one another
instead of seeing that person as being
difficult
we actually are recognizing that their
mind needs something different in that
moment in order to think
you